l'incontournable donc ça permet de
cibler de valoriser le patrimoine ancien
et puis en fait compte donc on parle
d'écologie on parle de protection de
l'environnement la forêt de rivière
pilote dont on parle de tout le
patrimoine martiniquais donc le fait
d'être là on est acteur n'est en fait
partie de tous donc c'est important
d'être dans ce maillot de cette fois
donc oui c'est important pour nous parc
national de la martinique d'être dans ce
mouvement
organisé par la commune d'ordinaire vie
d'autrui aujourd'hui en bas on a fini
bon ben fini ben elle et non en
martinique les néo gobain fidi boscéens
sernam donc le lendemain il a de grandes
oreilles
ben il est né
romantique et précision c'est un grand
c'est un âne donc son père c'est un
baudet du poitou donc le baudet du
poitou il un garrot une longue robe
effectivement donc positionnant le
contour des yeux blancs les naseaux
blanc le bas du ventre blanc
quoi dire sur l'âne encore donc les ânes
donc ce sont des azymes juste à côté on
a nos petits nous ben c'est un
championnat qui courent tous les 15 août
à sainte marie on peut aussi le
découvrir donc notamment sous le moulin
de valdonne à sainte anne donc comment
distinguer mulet donc au niveau des
oreilles donc les oreilles sont moyens
au niveau des contours des yeux donc la
capsule hier et prononcez le visage donc
un petit peu arrondie quoi dire donc on
voit cape sur le dos de tinh où on va
retrouver donc la croix de saint-andré
où la cua de palestine donc sont
limitées ou la religion
on dit que c'est jésus qui n'est rentré
au mont golgotha on a vu apparaître la
cua de s'étendre et donc ça fait partie
aussi des religions mais effectivement
tous les ans donc ils sont originaires
deux des aigles donc que le jeu disait
lane
il est stérile donc stérile donc
effectivement donc l'âme il faut avoir
donc des azymes donc à la case in dont
ils sont des ânes et les équidés ce sont
des chevaux et c'est l'homme qui a créé
justement cette espèce donc à l'état
naturel vont jamais vendeuse pettifer
toujours avoir la présence de la ddt
donc quoi dire ben je suis ravi d'être
sur cette foire